ce soir on vous propose une incursion
dans le monde ce trafic de cocaïne à
grande échelle ou des trafiquants sont
attirés par un style de vie extravagant
par la promesse d'une richesse extrême
je n'ai jamais connu des
narcotrafiquants prospère qu'ils soient
encore en vie y soit riche
ils finissent mort assassiné par des
gens de l'organisation renonça sûr mais
c'est un monde impitoyable ceux qui
veulent jouer dans la cour des grands
c'est un trafiquant est prêt à tout pour
atteindre son plus haut fait trio
criminal un peu aller jusqu'au meurtre
on vous a présenté l'an dernier
l'histoire de frédéric lavoie un homme
de québec se retrouver dans ce monde et
qui a payé de sa vie
c'est sûr qu'ils cherchaient tous les
moyens pour faire le plus d'argent
possible
je pense qu'il est mais reste heynckes
après lui apporter le sentiment pouvoir
on l'a retrouvée assassinée en colombie
finalement s'il est arrivé en colombie
c'est parce qu'auparavant les vues des
contacts au plus haut niveau c'est la
mafia qui est derrière ça marche ils
sont très puissants et l'autre il ya du
nouveau dans cette affaire et ce soit on
est même en mesure de vous dévoiler
l'identité du principal suspect d' sont
vertes et nadine destination grâce aux
enquêtes nous avons découvert qu'il
aurait présumément assassiné son
complice à sabaneta région d'antioquia
le grand risque est que l'erreur est
impardonnable
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
bonjour mesdames et messieurs vieux
cette conférence de presse en novembre
2012 la police frappe et démantèle un
réseau de trafiquants de drogue
l'opération s'appelle loquace nous
pouvons donc affirmer avoir réussi à
neutraliser ce réseau en portant des
accusations non seulement contre les
distributeurs mais également contre les
têtes dirigeantes de ce réseau six
hommes sont décrit par la police comme
les têtes du réseau
parmi eux il y en a un qui détonne
frédéric lavoie
un jeune homme de québec dont on n'a
jamais entendu parler des documents de
cour nous aident à vous raconter son
histoire de son ascension fulgurante
jusqu'à sa mort terrible loin des siens
ces traces nous ont amenés en colombie
[Musique]
encore aujourd'hui la colombie est le
principal producteur de cocaïne du monde
et ce pays est intimement lié à notre
histoire par ici c'est la seule
possibilité de travail qu'on a récolté
des feuilles de coca pour faire vivre
notre famille selon les nations unies la
colombie le pérou et la bolivie
produisent plus de 11 100 tonnes de
cocaïne par annie à la frontière le kilo
transformer se vendra jusqu'à 4 millions
vous avez obtenu combien pour la
produire à peine plus d'un million c'est
le prix après la transformation des
feuilles de coca en cocaïne
ce commerce deviez souvent le moteur de
l'économie des régions pauvres
une fois arrivés au canada le kilo vendu
dans la rue peut laisser jusqu'à 80
mille dollars de profits ces bénéfices
font rêver ceux qui veulent devenir
riche facilement les organisations
criminelles en profite pour recruter de
nouveaux membres
[Musique]
frédéric lavoie est né dans la région de
québec il y a grandi entouré de ses amis
et sa famille il travaille comme barman
sur la grande allée
cette personne a été proche de frédéric
lavoie
c'est la mission que leur a mis là
dedans c'est sûr c'est l'ambition avec
les résultats on peut voir que ça en
valait pas la peine
la voix n'avait pas le profil d'un
criminel une personne sans dossier
criminel
on peut devenir une personne très
important à l'heure ou à une
organisation criminelle
philippe palat fait des enquêtes dans le
monde des stupéfiants durant vingt ans
il connaît bien la mentalité des
trafiquants qui s'associe à des gens au
dossier sans tache
ces personnes leur semble aussi
judiciaire peuvent fréquenter et
traverser les douanes canadiennes
américaines ou autres sans laisser de
traces passé sous le radar
officiellement frédéric lavoie est un
entrepreneur qui tire ses revenus de
l'industrie du tatouage
en 2009 ils achètent un appartement dans
un édifice devenu célèbre le mille de la
commune
c'est un bel immeuble mais avec beaucoup
de logements ubik sont parfois loués à
des gens du crime organisé
pourquoi cette adresse là et ciblées par
ces gens là parce que c'est un endroit
pour fortifier un endroit sécurisé afin
de pouvoir transiger leurs activités à
l'abri de touche surtout de la police
l'ascension de frédéric lavoie aurait
été favorisée par les circonstances
selon la police c'était le bon moment
pour s'accaparer le marché de la drogue
il ya eu de nombreuses opérations
policières au cours des dernières années
qu'on parle d'eux le colisée qui était
fait par la gendarmerie royale jusque
duc
nador deux axes qui était faite par le
spvm ou de chars par les espoirs
régionale mixte salle a laissé une
certaine place à des organisations
criminelles
une de ces associations va mener la voie
jusqu'en colombie
[Musique]
nous sommes allés consulter un champion
de la lutte anti drogue de colombie
le général oscar naranjo le général nous
a donné cette entrevue quelques jours
seulement avant de devenir vice
président de la colombie ou juin alors
qu'adp à cassaber 10 à 20 ans un citoyen
canadien n'aurait jamais pensé venir
acheter de la drogue directement à la
source sur nidal punto de l'audi
aujourd'hui il peut penser que c'est
possible et ça l'est à pratiquer à
exposer et le passe à l'oscar que
l'escalier en contôle a dans le passé
les cartels voulait contrôler toutes les
étapes du narcotrafic et personne ne
venait jouer sur leur terrain
aujourd'hui ces organisations sont
globales et elles veulent minimiser les
risques est possible ici pour réduire
les risques
quelqu'un du canada doit venir en
colombie pour transporter la drogue les
cartes elles vont le permettre pour
faire parvenir la drogue à destination
les organisations collaborent plus que
jamais la cocaïne franchi de grandes
distances avant d'arriver aux
consommateurs on la transporte parfois à
travers la cordillère parfois sur les
fleuves
finalement la drogue arrive au port de
la côte pour être embarqués vers une
destination plus au nord en fait presque
toute la dhr poste par l'amérique
centrale ou pardo mexique
un arc ou trafiquant colombien a accepté
de nous parler de son commerce
à condition de cacher son identité on
envoie la drogue au mexique
ils sont responsables de la faire
rentrer clean au canada si on parle des
moyens de transport on peut dire qu'on
les utilise tous du voitures les avions
dernièrement on a envoyé de la
marchandise en utilisant des troncs de
bois et ça a bien marché en les envoyant
par bateau on est assez ingénieux on a
même et vendez des sous marins des semi
submersible comme celui ci peuvent
transporter jusqu'à 2 tonnes de cocaïne
côté pacifique la drogue peut transiter
par le canal de panama ou voyager
directement vers la côte est de
l'amérique du nord en passant par
l'amérique du sud où les antilles
une fois aux états unis ce sont les
cartels mexicains qui se charge de
transporter la drogue dans l'est du pays
c'est le célèbre cartel de sinaloa qui
s'en charge mais tous ces efforts ne
servent à rien si la drogue ne se rend
pas à bompas elle doit rentrer au canada
une porte d'entrée est une personne qui
va faciliter l'entrée de la drogue par
exemple un douanier qui va faciliter
l'entrée par un port d'entrée que ce
soit par camion ou par conteneurs
les organisations qui n'ont pas accès à
ces portes l'oeuvre ont tenté d'importer
de la drogue de toutes les façons
imaginaire possible que se soit caché
dans des plateaux de service dans les
avions
que se soit caché dans des ananas dans
les conteneurs dans les palettes de bois
pour transporter la marchandise ou autre
mais à chaque fois qu'il ya un risque
le risque de faire saisir la drogue des
associés de frédéric lavoie ont mis au
point un ingénieux moyen de transport
une entreprise et un propriétaire au
dossier sans tache servent de couverture
à l'importation de la drogue des camions
vont chercher des roulottes neuves aux
états unis en toute légalité
lors de procédures judiciaires récentes
un ancien chauffeur raconte comment il a
été recruté il me demandait si j'avais
mon passeport mon permis de conduire
j'avais pas de casier judiciaire il m'a
dit tu vas aller aux états unis tu va
amener du pote pouvoir ramener de
l'argent
il m'a dit que je ferais 3500 dollars
par voyage que jean frère à toutes les
semaines même des fois peut-être deux la
drogue est chargé dans un double fond on
passait à sarnia ou windsor
parce que c'est les deux grosses douanes
dans ce coin-là fallait passer à 7h et
7h30 le soir parce qu'on nous avait dit
qu'il y avait plus d'achalandage donc
passer moins de temps sur chaque
personne on disait aux douaniers ont sa
recherche
si on n'avait pas les roulottes
on a déposé deux unis c'était la
couverture idéale une fois la frontière
franchie
les instructions sont envoyés par
messagerie crypté sur blackberry
ces locaux recevaient notre destination
bon lot voit tant à la new york pour
telles personnes communiquent avec lui
at-elle numéro car au lieu d'aller
chercher la roulotte
le chauffeur bifurque vers son lieu de
livraison il livre le cannabis à l'un
des différents clients américains et
ramènent un sac d'argent
après le chauffeur récupère la roulotte
et revient vers l'ontario puis le québec
beau temps mauvais temps on file vers
l'entrepôt où l'argent est livré à
l'organisation le chauffeur raconte que
son patron est généreux une soirée dans
un bar ont dépensé 15 20 milles
ils paient tout le temps content il payé
la traite à tout le monde
le transport de vielles plus stressant
lors d'une livraison à chicago le
chauffeur fait face à des clients
mexique est plutôt nerveux et ramène une
cargaison inattendue on est allé dans un
entrepôt lot il y avait des hommes armés
avec des semi automatique
c'est là que j'ai vu qu'il se passait
quelque chose de différent parce que
j'avais jamais vu d'armes avant soit
dans aucun de mes transports pour la
première fois au lieu de sacs d'argent
le chauffeur rapportent des boîtes
remplies de cocaïne de retour au québec
le chauffeur se fait sermonner je me
suis fait dire que je pourrai pu
retourner à chicago parce que j'avais
conduit croche que je les avais mis sur
les nerfs dit que je n'avais pas avec
qui il faisait affaire que c'était des
cartels mexicains des gens vraiment
dangereux parce que ils voulaient me
retrouverai le témoin raconte qu'il est
allé travailler pour frédéric lavoie qui
selon lui s'approvisionner en cocaïne
grâce au stratagème des roulottes lui
c'est un fournisseur de cocaïne pour
montréal et les environs
je m'occupais d'aller voir si clients
d'apporter les kilos qui avait besoin de
récupérer l'argent de la comté j'allais
à tahoua sur la rive nord sur la rive
sud
partout il me disait d'aller qui logent
des pays au kilo que je transportais 250
dollars par kilo il y avait toute son
organisation à lui frédéric lavoie
il y avait six warner ces chauffeurs ses
associés ça roulait vraiment ces
affaires les parkings de centres
commerciaux sont témoins de rendez-vous
mystérieux où s'échangent la drogue et
l'argent parfois des centaines de
milliers de dollars
les proches de frédéric lavoie remarque
son train de vie c'est sûr que oui il y
avait un train de vie qui est justifiée
pas comment moi je les connaissais wendy
qui avaient beaucoup d'entreprises puis
aussi qui prêtaient de l'argent comme un
chat glock avec de l'intérêt élevé ce
qui était assez plausible la police
commence à s'intéresser à lui
les filatures les côtes électronique et
le travail d'agents d'infiltration
permettent d'en apprendre davantage sur
ses activités la police prépare une
opération majeure contre l'organisation
mais certains membres ont été prévenus
c'était il va y avoir une descente ce
soir ou dans les prochains jours je me
suis arrêté le lendemain le matin de
l'opération le 1er novembre 2012
frédéric lavoie n'est pas chez lui comme
plusieurs autres accusés
le public apprendra plus tard que c'est
le policier benoît roberge qui a prévenu
les moteurs de l'opération frédéric
lavoie part en cavale mais qui doit-il
craindre le plus la police ses présumés
complices ou bien d'autres criminels
[Musique]
medellin c'est une ville colombienne
très connu dans le monde
elle est synonyme de richesse
d'innovation et d'avenir
on oublie presque qu'elle a été l'une
des villes les plus violentes au monde
la capitale mondiale du narcotrafic et
le siège social du redoutable cartel de
medellin le nom de pablo escobar est
aujourd'hui une marque de commerce qui
attire les gens je dirais que la moitié
des gens aiment pablo surtout dans les
quartiers pauvres
pour eux c'est un héros mauricio est le
guide d'un tour de plus en plus convoité
par les étrangers deux américains qui
n'ont pas voulu être identifié nous ont
permis de faire la visite avec eux le
cartel de cali voulait tuer la famille
d'escobar ici même la famille de pablo
escobar a bien failli périr dans un
attentat avec moi même le de ses anciens
collaborateurs
caillemer gagne sa vie en racontant les
exploits de son patron on en resta
jusqu'à la tour sinon c'est lui qui a
commencé les tours guidés économique
avance à sept et a beau aborder mais
celui que l'on présente aujourd'hui
comme un mythe était dans les années 80
et 90 le plus grand exportateur de
drogue au monde après avoir tenté sa
chance comme politicien il s'est lancé
dans une véritable guerre contre les
autorités
bombay kidnapping il s'en est pris aux
policiers aux magistrats aux politiciens
il a fait des milliers de morts il est
devenu l'ennemi public numéro un
on est près de l'endroit où il a été tué
la police a tiré sur ses gardes du corps
et escobar a couru sur le toit
[Musique]
pablo escobar est ici omniprésent sa
tombe est toujours fleurie on a même
nommé un quartier en son honneur dans
les bidonvilles où il a construit des
maisons pour les pauvres du chapeau la
ville a essayé de changer le nom du
quartier
il ne voulait pas qu'on parle de pablo
escobar la légende jesco bas et plus
vivante que jamais à medellin
là où le narcotrafic n'a jamais cessé
elle décide ici c'est l'endroit où
escobar a grandi c'est un dégât d'eau
au nord de medellin se trouve la petite
municipalité dennevy gado ces deux lacs
pablo escobar gérer ses affaires avec
l'aide de son escadron de la mort qu'on
appelait la oficina de envigado le
bureau dennevy gado avant d'aller
commettre leur assassinat
les tueurs à gage qu'on appelle les
sicav y'as vont se recueillir devant la
vierge qui leur est dédié à la mort
d'escobar au lieu de disparaître cette
mafia de medellin est devenue plus
puissante et plus active que jamais un
bébé in plus de 13000 personnes
travaillent aujourd'hui pour cette
organisation
ce spécialiste du crime organisé vit
sous la menace des groupes criminels
son bureau est littéralement blindés et
il ne se déplace jamais sans ses gardes
du corps il s'appelle luis fernando qui
canaux on le consulte de partout car il
connaît les méandres du monde criminel
il explique comment fonctionne
aujourd'hui l'organisation qui a pris la
place du cartel de medellin et jonas
truc tout d'abord il y a les hommes de
main les tueurs underworld est alors au
dessus il y aller cherche t elle
puis le conseil de direction au siège
des représentants des différentes lans
mafieux haut de la hiérarchie retrouve
les patrons y mater les patrons des
patrons des patrons et staline préval
est impoli ce sont des entrepreneurs des
politiciens des autorités et ils sont
très puissants ou thema c'est une grande
entreprise avec un bras armé hall
imparato militaire
il confirme la présence criminelles
transnationales dans son pays
la présidente catherine aloi le cartel
mexicain de sinaloa est ici sont aussi
présentes les mafias russes chinoises et
italiennes oquendo hadiouche athènes la
passe et 12 à 12 heures quand elles font
la paix il y a moins d'homicides ça
diminue la violence a fait rayonner
violaine n'est pas la criminalité donc
et c'est ce qu'on vit à médine
aujourd'hui vieillot l'oqai oriane
nature
[Musique]
c'est dans cette réalité kateri frédéric
lavoie en mars 2014
il est en fuite depuis plus d'un an
après s'être caché aux bahamas pendant
plusieurs mois s'affiche d'interpol le
décrit comme l'un des criminels les plus
recherchés au canada quelques semaines
plus tard on découvre un corps aux
alentours de medellin
le cadavre démembré et emballés dans des
sacs en plastique a été trouvé par le
propriétaire d'un terrain tout près de
ce pan le corps est identifié par les
services de médecine légale c'est celui
de frédéric lavoie
ce crime ne peut avoir été commis sans
l'accord de la mafia locale négoce
certains sont venus de l'étranger et de
la mafia italienne pour faire des
affaires mais la mafia de medellin leur
a dit ici c'est nous qui avons le
contrôle et vous devez obtenir notre
père missionnaire permise aux nôtres
mais est il possible de commander un
assassinat en colombie depuis l'étranger
la suite de notre histoire pourraient
nous montrer que oui c'est très facile
on n'a qu'à faire en appel où on envoie
un message à nos partenaires d'affaires
et on leur demande d'embaucher quelqu'un
pour résoudre le problème et il s'en
occupe
[Musique]
nous avons poussé notre recherche dans
le monde interlope de medellin
un arc au trafiquant local confirme ici
on dit le chien danse grâce à l'argent
tout peut s'obtenir avec de l'argent
dans ce pays
il y a tellement d'inégalités que si
l'on offre de l'argent les gens vont
faire ce qu'on leur demande
notre visite ne passe pas inaperçu nos
recherches dérange surtout les
fonctionnaires de l'état
voici ce que nous rapporte notre
collaborateur un journaliste reconnu
amis des lions une de mes sources m'a
dit il ya quelque chose d'étrange dans
cette affaire-là que son patron qu'il ne
peut pas nommer lui a demandé qui est en
train de réveiller tout ça qu'est-ce
qu'il veut savoir au juste
ça fait des années que je travaille
comme journaliste et que je fais des
enquêtes
c'est la première fois qu'on met autant
de bâtons dans les roues des
informations nous parviennent alors du
monde criminel
c'est délicat parce que des policiers
seraient impliqués dans la mort de la
voix la question demeure pourquoi
frédéric lavoie a été tué de façon aussi
violente et surtout que venait-il faire
en colombie en tout cas ce présumé
trafiquant n'était pas comme les autres
[Musique]
ici c'est le paradis sur terre pour les
narcotrafiquants
ici on est tout près de la frontière
avec l'équateur
pour nous la plante de cocasse est une
bénédiction parce que ça nous permet
d'envoyer les enfants à l'école et
d'avoir deux pas manger les plantations
de coca sont immenses et les prix sont
bas c'est ce qui est site certains
étrangers à venir s'approvisionner sur
place c'est par la frontière de
l'équateur que frédéric lavoie seraient
entrés en colombie il s'est ensuite
rendu à medellin par avion dès son
arrivée et d'eric lavoie aurait essayé
de refaire son réseau d'importation de
cocaïne
le général procès et mendoça directeur
de la lutte contre la drogue a enquêté
sur ses activités à medellin il ne
s'agissait pas de trafic important
c'était plutôt planifier des envois de
drogue et utiliser des personnes comme
courrier des bulles
c'est ce que nous dit lankais au canada
le consortium criminelle dont auraient
fait partie frédéric lavoie était
composée de groupes du québec de l'ouest
canadien de la colombie du mexique et
même de la grèce une vraie
multinationales de la drogue mais qui
n'aurait pas de structures établies
comme les hells angels ou la mafia
n'étant pas sur des bases solides
ne connaissant pas tous les joueurs qui
travaillent au sein de son organisation
qui était restructuré au sein de
plusieurs groupes à ce moment là sur
risque de créer une faille 17 file à la
brèche fait en sorte que la police peut
infiltrer peut travailler plus
facilement une organisation qui n'a pas
l'expérience de contrer
toute infiltration policière à la suite
de l'opération loquace en 2012 on à
cusset six hommes d'avoir importé de
très grandes quantités de cocaïne et
d'en faire la distribution
parmi eux larry amero sur facebook
il ne cache pas son appartenance aux
hells angels il vient de colombie
britannique en 2011
la voiture qu'il conduisait a été
criblée de balles il était en compagnie
d'un trafiquant de drogue notoire mort
sur le coup dans la sphère locass qui
date de 2012
un juge a récemment décidé d'abandonner
les accusations contre lui pour cause de
délais déraisonnables en raison de
l'arrêt jordan chaîne kenneth malone et
lui a plaidé coupable à des accusations
de trafic de cocaïne dans ses entrepôts
on a aussi retrouvé un grand nombre
d'armes à feu et des explosifs
c'est pas le genre de personne qui va
que la police pour obtenir beaucoup de
détails parce que c'est un criminel
endurci et puis sa façon de faire
au cours des dernières années a fait en
sorte qu'ils devenu une étoile montante
du crime organisé mais ça reste dans mon
livre à moi un trafiquant notoire
deux des présumées têtes dirigeantes
identifiés dans le cas ce sont encore
devant les tribunaux n'y allez leventis
errabie al-khalil timoléon si harris
d'origine grecque était aussi en fuite
lors de la rafle policière de 2012
trois semaines plus tard on a retrouvé
son corps torturé et défigurée dans une
ville à l'est d'athènes les journaux
grecs mentionne la présence dans leur
pays des cartels mexicains pour
expliquer sa mort
frédéric lavoie qui n'était même pas
connu des services de police de sa
région s'est retrouvé dans ce groupe
comment at il fait est ce qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui vous laisser penser
qu'ils aient frédéric d'avoir couvert un
jour rentrer dans des affaires louches
vu de l'extérieur on s'imagine que c'est
des gens qui sont méchants pour être à
ce niveau là non il n'y avait pas sans
lui je les ai jamais vus être vraiment
méchant avec quelqu'un je vois pas
comment il aurait pu faire sa place là
dedans c'était quelqu'un de bien qui
était protecteur les femmes l'adoré
quelqu'un d'attentif et qui aimait
prendre soin des autres aussi dans un
message crypté écrit par la voix sous le
pseudonyme de king il réagit à la mort
accidentelle d'un complice si tu savais
comment j'étais proche de lui c'est un
gentil lui c'est pas comme les autres
hommes qui font du mal et à quel moment
tout s'est rendu compte que ce n est il
des vies étaient comme rosella de skill
norma massa devait être quand je lis vos
nouvelles comme quoi il était recherché
lorsque son corps est identifiée en juin
les témoignages de ses amis sur facebook
ne trompent pas fred tu vas me manquer
énormément mon frère je garderai
toujours de bons souvenirs il ya de ces
gens qui ne marque et des événements qui
ne faut pas toujours chercher à
comprendre
salvi de la voile jean tellez surtout du
côté où mais on essaie de faire le
parcours de sa vie
nous avons contacté sa famille et ses
amis mais peu d'entre eux ont accepté de
nous parler
la douleur est toujours vive et parfois
les sentiments sont ambivalents
cette personne a appris que frédéric
avait parfois caché de l'argent chez
elle à son issue est ce que nous sommes
ce qui n'était pas utilisé qu'à causer
du tort des répercussions autant sa
famille ses amis et un pas mal tout le
monde puis oui on sent trompé là dedans
c'est sûr puis je me demande moi si ou
le changement s'est fait à quel moment
dans sa vie dans sa tête
est ce qu'on est devenu moins importants
que ses propres bus dans les dernières
années je n'ai pas beaucoup vu
mais les fois où je l'aï vu c'était
impossible même pendant un dîner où une
rencontre d'avoir son attention
que 30 secondes à la fois parce que bon
il y avait trois quatre cellulaire était
tout le temps pressé était juste
concentré sur ses conversations avec ses
3 4 téléphone un texto fait qu'envoyer
locker tous qui vivait était très
préoccupant
la voix avait fait un voyage en colombie
à l'automne 2012
il veut alors développer un réseau
d'importation de drogue dans un
enregistrement réalisé à son issue il
révèle à son bras droit à voir former
une compagnie pour exporter de
l'équipement mécanique en colombie comme
frédéric lavoie a été tués en colombie
nous avons demandé au général oscar
naranjo décoré pour avoir combattu des
trafiquants toute sa carrière de se
pencher sur son histoire
comme environ pour les yeux en tant qu
ancien policier aujourd'hui à la
retraite
je peux vous mentionnez trois ou quatre
choses qui ont attiré mon attention la
ruine tout d'abord l'âge de ce garçon
comment at il fait pour se bâtir si
rapidement une carrière criminelle
devenir le 6ème criminel le plus
recherché au canada frédéric lavoie est
recherché en vertu d'un mandat
international
un code rouge c'est à dire lorsqu'on
l'identifient on doit l'arrêter avant
même qu'ils entrent en colombie les
autorités sont prévenus ils voyagent
avec un passeport des bahamas sous une
fausse identité ne traduit pas ça parle
très pâle sur un plateau derrière un
faux passeport
il y a une structure criminels
sophistiqués qui est dans ce cas à aider
ce canadien à venir en colombie alors on
peut conclure qu'on parle ici d'une
organisations criminelles
transnationales
pas de crime transnational importante
nos sources nous confirment que frédéric
lavoie avait des contacts en colombie
finalement s'il est arrivé en colombie
c'est parce qu auparavant il avait eu
des contacts au plus haut niveau
nous avons rencontré le général naranjo
au printemps 2017 et ils étaient
vraisemblablement bien informées ce que
nous avons appris dans les dernières
semaines
c'est que de ses contacts est un autre
canadien stephen skinner originaire de
halifax
skinner aurait dirigé une organisation
criminelle
en colombie une organisation sous la
protection du narcotrafiquant daniel
barreira que le général naranjo à
pourchasser durant toute sa carrière
les mines où cet individu est devenu en
quelque sorte mon obsession obsession
pellet connu dans le monde criminel sous
le nom de locaux barreira locaux
barreira alias le fou a été arrêté en
2012 et extradé aux états unis mais il
est toujours le parrain de ce réseau
lorsque frédéric lavoie arrive en
colombie en mars 2014
il est attiré par la perspective de se
renflouer financièrement il vient
rencontrer stephen king steven daigle au
scanner est natif de halifax
il est connu pour avoir participé à de
nombreux combats d'arts martiaux mixtes
parfois comme professionnel mais il est
aussi connu des policiers de halifax
particulièrement depuis 2010 cette
année-là il est accusé de voies de fait
graves et de menaces de mort la couronne
a depuis demandé un arrêt des procédures
dans ce dossier mais en 2011 la police
de la nouvelle écosse le recherche pour
le meurtre au deuxième degré celui d'un
jeune homme de 20 ans stacy adams
[Musique]
mais steven skinner s'est déjà enfui du
pays pour rejoindre la colombie peu de
temps après skinner accueil frédéric
lavoie à son arrivée à medellin
ensemble ils préparent un projet
d'exportation de cocaïne
la voix pense avoir une chance de
refaire sa fortune et sa vie qu on
présente souvent une seule facette du
nord coréens sur la ligne on peut
devenir immensément riche grâce à la
drogue de l'argent est devenu la
principale motivation des jeunes comme
celui ci ou croient qu'ils peuvent
devenir très riche du jour au lendemain
peu importe qu'ils courent le risque de
mourir
après la pause qui avait intérêt à
dessus frédéric lavoie
[Musique]
medellin est aujourd'hui une destination
touristique recherché mais elle cache
toujours une autre réalité la plupart
des touristes viennent profiter de la
ville de son climat et de la gentillesse
des personnes quelques-uns viennent pour
la drogue les femmes et le sexe drogue
et sexe
la combinaison parfaite pour les
touristes qui cherchent ce qu'on appelle
la rumba doura
ici c'est bon pour les affaires
la rumba les femmes l'exploitation
sexuelle les prix de file la
pornographie infantile ici c'est la
nouvelle
mais il ya aussi ces étrangers dont des
canadiens qui viennent ici pour
s'associer à des organisations
criminelles
parfois ils et laissent leur vie de 2016
quatre étrangers ont été assassinés les
étaient reliés au trafic de drogue et à
la pédophilie c'est un trafiquant est
prêt à tout pour atteindre son but était
ok minal n'hésite pas à faire pression
sur les gens paraissent lionel il peut
aller jusqu'au meurtre
il a selon elle est causée par l'indicé
selon les autorités colombiennes
frédéric lavoie est entré en colombie
quelques semaines avant sa mort enquête
a appris que juste avant d'être
assassiné un envoyé de la voix ramasser
de l'argent au canada pour lui je pense
qu'ils allaient voir aussi plusieurs
personnes pour de l'argent est-ce
qu'elle ferait dans le besoin par ce qui
est en cavale où ils le devaient
je sais pas j'ai aucune idée pourquoi y
avait besoin d'argent
aucune idée d'où ce qui était non plus
pourquoi frédéric lavoie at il été
assassiné selon notre enquête
l'opération le casse a entraîné des
pertes de millions de dollars pour les
organisations criminelles qui en faisait
partie
comme les cartels mexicains qui
fournissait la cocaïne transportée par
les roulottes jusqu'au canada
ils ont perdu beaucoup dans cette
histoire l'argent mais surtout une porte
d'entrée pour acheminer la drogue
l'organisation criminelle est en droit
d'avoir des réponses et souvent on va
convoquer ces personnes là dans le pays
instigateur dans le pays d'où vient la
drogue que ce soit la colombie le
mexique ou autres pays producteurs
et puis si les réponses ne satisfait pas
aux besoins mais des grosses chances que
ces personnels s'ils au canada vous me
renvoyez plus jamais
nous savons également que l'opération
s'appelle loquace parce que frédéric
lavoie parlait trop rappelons que
l'homme qui a infiltré son organisation
et qui témoigne maintenant dans les
procès était son bras droit
l'infiltrateur raconté à la police ce
que la voix lui confier bien naïvement
le grand risque est celui de transiger
comme vous avez dit dans la cour des
grands dans une matière où ce que tu
n'as pas tellement l'habitude de faire
et que l'erreur est impardonnable
cette trahison expliquerait également le
traitement cruel infligé à frédéric
lavoie et cela m'a donné la houssoye la
main en colombie c'est la façon typique
de la mafia pour punir les trahisons et
en laissant le faux passeport ceux qui
l'ont assassiné voulais qu'il soit
identifié pour envoyer un message s'est
associé au canada mais a promis au
vainqueur
c'est la mafia qui est derrière ça des
gens très puissants que ça dérange et
qui même des années plus tard ne veulent
pas qu'on en parle ça alerté tout le
monde avant que notre équipe quitte la
colombie en avril 2017
on apprend que deux policiers ont été
arrêtés dans la sphère la voix et les
fecteau c'est l'ogre à la cocteau
rehaussé fonctionnaires de la police
effectivement nous avons arrêté deux
policiers qui auraient été engagés pour
faire disparaître le corps du canadien
le jour il a été tué et deux personnes
ont déjà comparu devant un juge
ils ont été formellement accusés
aujourd'hui les deux policiers sont
toujours en attente de leur procès ils
ne sont pas accusés de meurtre seulement
de s'être débarrassé du cadavre
ils disent ignorer qui a assassiné la
voie au début de notre enquête on ne
savait pas qui était le cerveau derrière
l'assassinât de frédéric lavoie
mais il était clair que ce meurtre ne
pouvait pas s'expliquer par une simple
transaction qui a mal tourné
[Musique]
l'attention des enquêteurs va se porter
sur celui qui accompagnait frédéric
lavoie dans ces derniers jours en
colombie la suite de notre enquête dans
un instant
[Musique]
hemus nous avons démantelé un réseau qui
vendait de la cocaïne liquide cocaïne
liquide
en septembre dernier le procureur de la
colombie annonce le démantèlement d'un
réseau de trafiquants de drogue
une enquête de quatre ans menés à
travers plusieurs villes de colombie a
permis d'arrêter 27 individus
une organisation qui se nomme mort fox
shox l'opération contre mort fox date de
le bureau du procureur a reçu un avis
des autorités canadiennes à propos d'un
citoyen canadien nommé steven douglas
kane recherché par interpol concept
couleur or à interpol l'organisation
utilisait des personnes âgées et des
femmes au foyer pour transporter vers
l'étranger de la cocaïne liquide dans
leur estomac la cocaïne ali la cocaïne
liquide n'est pas détectée par les
scanners des aéroports le procureur
parle ensuite d'un meurtre qui aurait
commis ce qu'est né en colombie sans
amis la victime et nadine destination
grâce aux enquêtes
nous avons découvert que ce qui nous
aurait présumément assassiné son
complice à sabaneta région d'antioquia
le bureau du procureur nous a confirmé
que ce complice c'est nul autre que
frédéric lavoie
d'après les autorités colombiennes les
jours avant sa mort la voix résidait au
sud de medellin et il fréquentait steven
scanner la voix auraient été amenés dans
une ferme des environs où il a été
torturé et assassiné scanner aurait
présumément participer à ce meurtre aux
régimes montillot pour cette raison
skinner s'est enfui au venezuela où il a
été capturé dans des foires cap toulalan
stevens qui nous est arrêté en 2016 par
la police sur une plage de l'île de
margarita la police publie cette photo
après plusieurs mois il est extradé au
canada par la voix de son avocat
monsieur skinner a refusé de commenter
les allégations des autorités
colombiennes en jeu 2017 steven skinner
comparer enfin à dartmouth en nouvelle
écosse
il doit subir son procès pour le meurtre
au deuxième degré john stacey adams
c'est sa mère qu'on voit ici une autre
mère dont le fils est tombé victime d'un
milieu impitoyable comme frédéric lavoie
et beaucoup d'autres nationale contre la
mécanique je n'ai jamais connu des
narcotrafiquants prospère qu'ils soient
encore en vie
qu'ils soient riches ils finissent
pauvres ou en prison ou mort assassiné
par des gens de l'organisation
toute cette histoire c'est une grande
tragédie
quand les proches de frédéric lavoie ans
après sa mort ce fut un choc
ils ont souffert d'avoir perdu celui
qu'ils aimaient profondément ya pas été
élevé dans un milieu criminel ça doit
être dur de ce côté là ma grande
inquiétude c'est que cette consommation
des drogues alimente la violence et
cette violence peut mettre fin à la vie
des jeunes comme ce canadien qui est
venue mourir dans un pays étranger loin
de sa famille et de son payer assassiné
par la mafia
on espère que vous avez apprécié ce
reportage de ce soir et on va continuer
de suivre les développements dans ce
dossier avant de vous quitter je vous
présente un extrait de ce que vous allez
voir bientôt en quête edmonton
chaque année la capitale albertaine
accueille des dizaines de milliers
d'immigrants mais en 2010 une résidence
unifamiliale attire l'attention d'agents
du ministère d'immigration mais on
semble plus impopulaire auprès
d'immigrants chinois un peu trop même
les agents découvrent que sur une
période de huit mois plus de 40 migrants
chinois nouvellement arrivés au canada
ont déclaré y vivre
les agents observent le même phénomène
dans d'autres résidences à calgary à
edmonton et richmond en
colombie-britannique une immigrante dont
l'adresse au dossier est à edmonton
concède qu'elle n'a jamais vécu dans la
capitale albertaine
elle est même incapable de reconnaître
le nom de la province
et ce reportage ce sera au tour du temps
des fêtes ont fait relâche jusqu'au 17
janvier
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là et de la
part de toute l'équipe d' enquête de
très joyeuses fêtes
[Musique]